Star Trek Picard boldly went backwards
in his best season yet but the whole TNG
crew back in the mix you know there's
enough Easter eggs to fill the alpha
quadrant these are the ones you may have
missed
the series opens with the text in the
25th Century in stylized blue type face
over black this will be familiar to fans
of Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan which
begins with the phrase in the 23rd
Century in that same print this is the
first signal that this season of Star
Trek Picard will borrow liberally from
the popular film in addition to a few
blob beats throughout the season the
series has a definite aesthetic fondness
for the entire era of movies with the
original series cast the alarm clock
CERN in Beverly Crusher ship indicating
a security breach is the same one that
sounds when Spock's quarters are invaded
in Star Trek 3 the search for spark
likewise the style of the jacket that
Beverly wears in the episode's teaser is
reminiscent of the away team jacket from
The Wrath of Khan which has a similarly
broad color later when we get a look at
the redesigned hand phases we can see
that they've reverted to something
closer to the swept back models from the
classic era very much like those seen in
the Search for Spock and the
Undiscovered Country of course there's
also the design of the USS Titan a a
which is identified as a
neo-constitution class refit it's
because the silhouette that's closer to
the refit Constitution class of the
original series films than any of the
Next Generation era ships and throughout
the season it appears that rectangular
warped nay cells have come back into
fashion at the turn of the 21st Century
season 3 of Star Trek Picard is plainly
designed to be consumed independently
from the first two seasons of the series
most of the original characters
introduced earlier are absent or have
reduced roles still the series does make
a subtle acknowledgment of its own
Origins our first images of the season
are a brief Montage of beautiful and
peaceful images of Stellar phenomena
with an early 20th century ballad
playing underneath it this is also how
the first episode of the series
remembrance begins in that episode the
soundtrack was blue skies by Irving
Berlin as performed by Bing Crosby a
song that data sang at Riku and Troy's
wedding in Star Trek Nemesis season 2 of
Picard also uses a 20th century ballad
in its opening episode in that case
Jenner regrets Rihanna by Edith Piaf
this time our opening number is I don't
want to set the world on fire by The Ink
Spots this tune has no prior history
with Star Trek but might be familiar to
gamers in the audience as it features in
the Fallout series
episode 1's first scenes are set aboard
an unfamiliar Starship the Elios where
the camera pans across a cluttered desk
eagle-eyed fans will quickly put
together that this workspace belongs to
Dr Beverly Crusher thanks to a number of
obscure visual Clues these include
classic drama masks recalling Crushers
love a theater and the same sorts of
flowers that she tends on her courses in
the Next Generation episode cause and
effect a computer is playing back one of
Captain Picard's log entries from The
Best of Both Worlds and the following
log in the queue is the one that opens
in counter at farpoint the premiere
episode of The Next Generation she has a
plaque awarded to a medical away team as
honorary citizens of core Carol I5
likely in recognition of a mission that
we hear about but never actually see in
the Next Generation episode Allegiance
we have finally succeeded in eradicating
the fire rocks playing on core karolai 5
and will soon be preparing to leave
orbit and proceed to our next mission
since these are all pretty obscure
references we then pan down to a more
obvious one the FootLocker of Beverly's
late husband Lieutenant Commander Jack
Crusher
just as in previous seasons of Star Trek
Picard jean-luc's home in the bar France
displays a number of artifacts that are
familiar to trekkies a few of these
items receive some special attention in
the scene where Picard does some spring
cleaning with his girlfriend lares first
of course is a large painting of the USS
Enterprise D that used to hang in his
ready room in the Next Generation which
he considers giving to Jordy laforge and
the Starfleet Museum just below it
there's also a sexton from the mantle
that may be the one from Picard's
quarters the mintakan tapestry from who
watches the watches are used to drape
over his chair on both Enterprises to
the dawns a chair behind his desk at
home there's a bajoran Memento gold
models of both Enterprise D and
Enterprise E and finally his recipient
flew from the inner light perhaps the
most pressures of all his mementos as it
is his only Keepsake from his lifetime
of memories on the long dead planet's
Katan later he sits handwriting a note
and the curl and nescar's a precious
archaeological artifact and the gift
from his mentor Professor Galen can be
seen on his table we get one additional
reference here as the authorization code
that Picard uses to decrypt Beverly's
message is Picard 47 Alpha Tango the
same security code that he uses to
activate the auto destruct sequence on
the Enterprise E in Star Trek first
Contact
after receiving Beverly's encrypted
distress call Picard meets up with his
old friend Riker at the 10 forward
Lounge in Los Angeles while reminiscing
Riker mentions that the crew of the
Enterprise had previously used Beverly's
Myriad Kodak to encrypt their
Transmissions while on a mission to
rigel 7. however ride or 7 is a planet
whose first and only appearances in the
original Star Trek Pilots the cage from
1965. though this footage would later be
reused in the classic 1966 two-parter
The Menagerie the incident to which Riku
refers has never been depicted or
mentioned before on screen the hellbird
virus that offers a final clue to
decoding Beverly's location is another
new addition to the Canon a background
plot retconned Into The Best of Both
Worlds we learned that the Borg
attempted to foul the Enterprise's
navigation using a computer virus while
Picard was held captive as lucutus of
Borg I
resistance is futile
when Picard summons Riker to the 10 Ford
Bar in Los Angeles we learned that there
is an upcoming celebration planned for
Frontier day subscribe to staff leads
250th anniversary for this day to line
up with where we appear to be in the
show's timeline it would have to be a
celebration not of starfleet's founding
but of its first deep space mission
which launched in 2051 under the command
of Captain Jonathan Archer The
Adventures of this first Starship
Enterprise also known as the nx-01 are
the subject of the prequel television
series Star Trek Enterprise which aired
on UPN from 2001 to 2005. out of the
five first live-action Star Trek series
Enterprise is the one that tends to get
the least love though there is the
occasional none to its historical
significance in the universe such as the
christening of Archer space dark on
season 4 of Star Trek Discovery how can
we have so many Enterprise Deeds oh the
fat ones no one wants those
you better leave the bottle incidentally
the souvenir Starship models up for sale
in 10 forward appear to be items from
the eagle Moss collection of Star Trek
Starships eaglemoss declared bankruptcy
during the height of the covid-19
pandemic after producing over 400 unique
Starship models from across the Star
Trek Canon matalis primed the neon-lit
city planet where Commander Rafi musica
is working undercover for Starfleet
intelligence is named for Picard's
showrunner Terry matalis who also wrote
this episode however he didn't name the
planet after himself the planet was
first introduced in Dialogue on a 2002
episode of Star Trek Enterprise by
showrunner Brannan bragger for whom
metallis was working as an assistant but
Talis would return to Star Trek years
later to become co-show Runner of Picard
season 2 with Akiva goldsmen before
finally taking the Reigns for its final
run batallas's fingerprints are all over
this season fans of his previous series
sci-fi's 12 Monkeys will recognize the
actor playing Captain Shaw that's Todd
stashweck who played the villainous
Deacon on 12 Monkeys he also guest
starred on a 2004 episode of Star Trek
Enterprise as Tarlac a Vulcan officer
who turns out to be an undercover
Romulan spy
the card and Riker's shuttle approach
towards the USS Titan is very evocative
of similar sequences in which Captain
Kirk and Company return to the refitted
USS Enterprise in the various chapters
of the original Star Trek film series
Once Picard and Riker are aboard the
Titan references to Star Trek 2 the
Wrath of Khan continue as a crewman
blows into a digital bosons whistle to
Signal their arrival the same ritual is
performed and Kirk is welcomed aboard
the Enterprise in The Wrath of Khan and
the prop used is almost identical to the
one played by Yeoman Burke in Star Trek
6 the Undiscovered Country the influence
of the original series era of Star Trek
films extends to non-diegetic sound
choices as well the arrangement of the
musical score when Picard and Riker
enter the bridge of the Tyson and the
entire sequence of the ship's departure
from space dock are extremely
reminiscent of James Horner's score from
a parallel scene in The Wrath of Khan
though composer Stephen Barson also
incorporates an original Motif for this
series and Jerry Goldsmith's famous
theme from the motion picture and the
Next Generation in his Arrangements
about the feeling of the Wrath of Khan
and the Search for Spock for viewers who
may not recognize it outright if you
want to hear The Inspirations for these
compositions listen to Enterprise clears
Moorings from The Wrath of Khan
soundtrack there's even a brief quote
from Cliff edelman's score from the
Undiscovered Country as the ship emerges
from the space dog doors
when Rafi asked the computer to name all
the big events coming up in the next few
months they're pretty ridiculous request
considering we're talking about the
entire galaxy here the computer displays
a whopping three results first the
Gratitude Festival a bejoran holiday
first seen in the Deep Space Nine
episode Fascination Empire Union day is
a Klingon holiday mentioned only in a
quasi-educational audio tape called
Power Klingon released in 1993 as part
of a series of books and tapes about the
Klingon language by its inventor
linguist Mark ocrand long out of Prince
and remembered only by those who study
the language this is about as deep as
deep cut references get the red lady
Rafi learns about from a contact on
matalis turns out to be a code name for
a statue being dedicated at a Starfleet
recruitment center the statue on its
Captain Rachel Garrett commander of the
USS Enterprise C whose only appearances
in the Next Generation episode
yesterday's Enterprise Garrett is killed
in battle while coming to the aid of a
Klingon Colony under Romney an attack
this is a more pivotal moment in history
than it seemed as Garrett and her Cruise
sacrifice helped to avert Decades of War
also on screen drawing the Cena images
of a few starships that have not made
Canon appearances before including the
odyssey-class USS Enterprise F which was
designed via a fan contest for the game
Star Trek online
in the opening episode of season 3
Admiral Picard and Captain Riker
commandeer one of the USS Titans
shuttlecraft for an unauthorized rescue
mission to Dr Beverly Crusher ship the
SS Elios however in the following
chapter disengage the shuttle is
destroyed as the wreckage flies towards
the camera we get a clear look at the
shuttle's name the savic the vessel's
namesake is a junior officer introduced
in Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan where
she was portrayed by Kirsty alley in her
first major film role
call me
Wing us
Lieutenant savik was Spock's Protege
unseen position to take his place as a
regular member of the Enterprise crew
after Spock's death at the end of that
film however when Spock actor Leonard
Nimoy decided not to leave the franchise
savic was recast and gradually given
smaller roles in the next two films
before disappearing altogether that is
until a recent official Star Trek
franchise Instagram post revealed that
savic eventually Rose to the rank of
Captain and took command of the first
USS Titan in the late 23rd Century
making the shuttlecraft's name a tribute
to her Legacy anytime you see a wall of
text on a display in Star Trek you're
bound to find a few Easter eggs
disengage features quite a few in the
criminal record for the Ferengi gangster
Sneed sneeze lists of known associates
include some familiar names from Star
Trek Deep Space Nine quarker
faranganaris of course a series scheming
bartender though by this point in the
Star Trek timeline he's also the owner
of a franchise of bars and gambling
establishments bearing his name as seen
on Star Trek lower decks and in previous
seasons of Picard brunt is quark's
nemesis from the Ferengi Commerce
Authority played by Star Trek's Man Of A
Thousand Faces Jeffrey Combs mourn of
luria is quark's most steady customer
appearing in 93 episodes of Deep Space
Nine and never speaking a word the final
name on Snead's list of known associates
is Sadie and O'Connor a Smuggler and
Playboy who first appeared in the
infamously campy episode of Star Trek
the Next Generation called the
outrageous O'Connor now that's sex
appeal he has sense of being an animated
form on both lower decks and Star Trek
Prodigy we can now add a reference in
Picard to his surprisingly illustrious
resume
while investigating the destruction of
the Starfleet recruitment center
Commander Rafi musica looks into the
criminal record of the Romulan Outlaw
Lorac toluko whom star Fleet is named as
a perpetrator Rafi disagrees believing
him to be too small time for such a
serious crime over rafi's shoulder we
get a quick look at taluko's history
which references Two Worlds that have
never been seen in Canon but
nevertheless of long histories in the
Star Trek franchise the planet's vendor
and rattor 3 were both first mentioned
in a 1973 episode of Star Trek the
Animated Series entitled The Survivor
the shape-shifting vandorians introduced
in that episode wouldn't make another
appearance on television until lower
decks brought them back for a gag in
season 3 of Star Trek Picard payso Mars
to the style and tone of the original
six Star Trek feature films so it's only
appropriate that The Season's
antagonists be kept from the same cloth
as those Classic Movie Villains the
casting of Amanda Plummer as a Vasily
Captain vardik it's surely no accident
her late father Christopher Plummer
portrayed the Klingon General Chang in
Star Trek 6 the Undiscovered Country in
1991. their characters have no direct
relation but there are definitely some
stylistic connections beyond their
actors Family Ties both antagonists
plainly Relish in their villainy
indulging in a flowery speeches and
Theatrical intimidation ridiculous do we
not laugh prick us do we not bleed
wrong us
shall we not Revenge the fact that both
Chang and vardik twirl around in their
big Captain's chairs and Order their
Crews to open fire with casual flicks of
the wrist might just be a coincidence or
it could be a knowing tribute from a
daughter to the father in whose
footsteps she Treads however it's almost
certainly deliberate that during
vardik's menacing view screen
conversation and disengage as sound
designers for Picard have brought back
the same ominous Communications Claxton
used to punctuate Jennifer Chang's hails
in Star Trek 6.
when Wolff introduces himself to Rafi a
matalis prime he reads off a list of
impressive sounding titles accumulated
over the course of his 281 appearances
across TNG DS9 and the TNG movies he is
the son of Moog a Klingon dignitary who
was killed by romulans when he was a
young boy he is also the son of Sergey
of house roshenko referring to his
adoptive human parents Sergey and Helena
roshenko Wharf also names himself as a
member of the House of matak the family
that he was inducted into during Deep
Space Nine after breaking out of
dominion prison with General Martock
honor has been satisfied
referencing when he defeated the
dishonorable Klingon High Chancellor in
single combat and installed martak in
his place in the late DS9 episode
tucking into the wind finally he's
banged to the duras family his Nemesis
since early in the Next Generation Doras
is a house of the Klingons who betrayed
Wolf's parents of the romulans and later
killed his mate Kayla dwarf in turn has
killed three of the last four heads of
the House of duras duras himself and his
two sisters and Beto and bested their
Heir torale in combat
the third episode 17 seconds reveals
that the masterminds behind the attack
on the Starfleet recruitment center are
changelings major antagonists introduced
in DS9 as their name suggests
changelings are shapeshifters whose
natural state is liquid they have the
ability to perfectly imitate any person
creature or object they choose they
command the Dominion an Empire even more
vast and powerful than the Federation
located in the distant gamma quadrant in
Picard Wharf tells Rafi that he has been
contacted by a friend from the
changelings great link who warns him
that a splinter group of changelings is
aiming to attack the Federation it's not
confirmed but this man of honor is
likely none other than Odo the former
Chief of security of space station Deep
Space Nine though a changeling himself
Odo fought on the side of the Federation
in the Dominion War serving with then
Lieutenant Commander Wolff throughout
the conflict after the Dominion
surrender Odo returned to the great Link
in order to cure his people of a deadly
virus and help to foster a lasting peace
the who memorably played Odo Rene
oberger passed away in 2019
Picard's fourth episode no win scenario
opens with a flashback to five years
before the events of this season in
which retired Admiral Picard is enjoying
a meal at guinen's ten forward Lounge in
Los Angeles while there a group of young
officers asked Picard about his
encounter with the herojian a species of
ritualistic hunters who made their debut
in Star Trek Voyager hence the mention
of Admiral Janeway the adventuring
question is one we've never seen before
and would have taken place between Star
Trek Nemesis and Star Trek Picard this
isn't the only reference to our rojin on
Picard however as one of the ex-borgs
seen on the artifact in the season 1
episode in Nepenthe is an assimilated
heroin later in the episode picardo
Regal several admirers of the story of
the classic TNG episode darmark in which
Picard attempts to survive in a hostile
world with an alien Captain who speaks
only in idioms this is the one that
Picard would see most likely to enjoy
recalling it's a dilemma that was solved
through patience compassion and
communication it also happens to be one
of the best episodes of TNG
when seven of nine first searches
transporter officer Fosters quarters
there's a familiar artifact on his desk
a messy stack of thin metal cylinders
arranged in a shape like a tumbleweed
this is kalto a Vulcan strategy game
enjoyed by Lieutenant Commander tuvak
and other members of the Voyager crew 7
is particularly Adept at the game and is
seen effortlessly defeating veteran
player tuvak in the episode The Omega
directive seven has also been seen
teaching the game to Rafi in the final
moments of the Picard season 1 finale
later in no win scenario Captain Shaw
suggests that seven surge Fosters
quarters again to find a part of ours in
which Fosters changeling imposter may
have hidden more sleeping in liquid form
seven checks inside a light fixture and
finds a bucket that's more or less
identical to the one that Constable Odo
of Deep Space Nine used to sleep in this
was a pretty silly inclusion given that
odo's bucket is not a traditional
changeling artifact instead it's
something he would have acquired from
the Kardashians long before he even knew
the other changelings existed while Odo
has since joined the great link which
would immediately share the knowledge of
his habit with the entire species it's
unlikely that the changelings would want
to honor his people's one and only
traitor
Picard finally clarifies a baffling
piece of Star Trek Cannon involving the
franchise's famous simulator room the
hollow deck when the USS Voyager was
held halfway across the Galaxy the
ship's crew was forced to Brave a long
dangerous Journey back to Federation
space with no allies or support despite
concerns about the ship's limited energy
Supply leading to replicator rationing
voyages Hollow decks a purely
recreational system remained in service
for the entire seven-year Mission the
series handwaves this by explaining that
Hollow decks have their own independent
power source that is incompatible with
the rest of the ship but it feels a lot
more like an excuse for the writers to
continue to tell the Next Generation
style Hollow deck fantasy story despite
the more dire Stakes of Voyager Anton
Kim have you had any luck getting power
from the Holodeck reactors not yet
we tried hooking them to the power grid
and we ended up blowing out half the
relays Picard finally offers an
explanation as to why star Fleet would
give its Hollow decks their own power
source so that they can be used as a
pleasant sanctuary in the events that
the ship should be damaged Beyond repair
there the crew could enjoy a nice
diversion while say plummeting holds the
sea Into the Heart of a gravity wear as
a Titan does during this episode this
allows Jean-Luc and his son jack Crusher
to share a quiet moment in a simulation
of 10 forward while the rest of the ship
systems are on the fritz it's a flimsy
explanation but it's better than nothing
in no win scenario the mysterious
Captain vardik uses an ornate dagger to
slice off her own hand which transforms
into the face of a changeling Overlord
if this dagger looks familiar it should
this is a jackal crafted by knivesmith
Gil hibben and employed in an assortment
of genre movies and TV shows for
instance it's the Rogue vampire Hunter
face signature weapon on Buffy the
Vampire Slayer it's also not the first
time the Jackal has appeared in Star
Trek Canon it played the role of a
ceremony or rieman dagger used by Tom
Hardy's prey tour shinzon in Star Trek
Nemesis even being featured on the
film's theatrical poster there's no
indication however that is supposed to
be the same knife it's likely just an
Easter egg for fans as well as a nod to
one of the cooler custom blades ever
made for the Silver Screen
drawing his tirade in the 10 forward
Hollow deck simulation the Titans
Captain Shaw reveals that he is a
veteran of the battle of wolf 359 the
federation's devastating defeat at the
hands of the Borg this battle takes
place during the famous and Next
Generation two-parter The Best of Both
Worlds in which Picard is assimilated by
the Borg and forced to lead their
Invasion Force
are born
resistance
is futile in those episodes though only
the aftermath of the massacre is seen in
that story our first and only canonical
Glimpse that the battle comes in the
opening scenes of Emissary the first
episode of Star Trek Deep Space Nine in
which we learn that Benjamin Cisco is
also a survivor of wolf 359 sure served
aboard the USS Constance diagrams of the
constants also appear during the closing
credits of the Season which identified
as a constellation-class Starship
Picard's fifth episode imposter reveals
of this latest crop of changeling
infiltrators has mastered the ability to
replicate the internal structure of
whatever species they've morphed into
this allows them to circumvent any
existing method of detection the
Federation put in place during the
Dominion War this is meant to
demonstrate that the typical process for
proving someone isn't a changeling by
extracting blood from them and ensuring
that it doesn't turn into goo isn't
effective any longer this isn't as huge
a development as it seems to be as
taking blood has never been a reliable
way to determine whether or not someone
is a changeling the shape-shifters had
already found a way around the standard
blood test Midway through Deep Space
Nine in the season 4 premiere the way of
the warrior Klingon General Marta cuts
his hand to prove he is who he claims to
be a year later we learned that this
smart talk is in fact a changeling and
that the real madsaka's been imprisoned
in the gamma quadrant since before his
doppelganger's first appearance on the
show Captain Cisco's Father Joseph has
his own Theory as to how this works in
the episode home front Joseph de
Chrysler uselessness of subjecting
citizens to blood screenings he points
out that a changeling could easily store
real blood within its assumed body in
case it ever needed to prove its
identity the changelings we see in
Picard are definitely more advanced
given their ability to retain their form
even when dead or unconscious but the
ability to fall a blood tests isn't
actually a major feature of the upgrade
imposter also sees sure we take command
of his ship from the mutinous Picard and
Riker as he escorts Picard and Riker to
their hearing with Starfleet
intelligence his two Rivals defend
themselves by mentioning the number of
times they've saved the entire galaxy in
response to Sean lists off a few
examples of when the crew of Picard's
Enterprise broke bad arguing that saving
the Federation a few times has made
their service records a wash of best
first Shaw mentions a crash landing of
the Enterprise d sorcer section in Star
Trek generations this may be an iconic
moment of Star Trek Cinema but it really
shouldn't be held against them as an
emergency source of Landing is just one
of the ship's safety features working
exactly as design we accept no slander
of counselor Troy's piloting scales
foreign
also brings up Picard's Rebellion
against the Federation in Star Trek
insurrection which he implies was
motivated by Picard's desire to sleep
with charming Baku villager onige then
again seeing as Picard was disobeying
orders to save the Baku helped to
prevent Starfleet from participating in
a genocide it's a little disingenuous to
frame Picard is a bad guy in this one
too as for the third incident he
mentions in which Picard almost wipes
out all life in the Galaxy by creating a
spatial anomaly that grows backward
through time in the TNG finale All Good
Things sure may have a point it's hard
to give for card credit for preventing
Pan Galactic Doom when his time
traveling cause a threat to begin with
imposter boasts a long awaited return of
fun favorite character rohleren who
hasn't been seen since the next to last
episode of TNG Picard's most complicated
Protege Roe joins a crew of the
Enterprise during season five and
appears in a total of eight episodes the
character was popular enough amongst
fans and writers that she was intended
to feature in the cast of Deep Space
Nine but actor Michelle Forbes was
reluctant to sign an extended contract
this led to the character of Kira neris
being created in her place a different
fate was written for Roe who closes out
her run on the Next Generation by
defecting from Starfleet to join the
human and bajoran resistance group
called The Marquee you're going with
them
foreign
since I really felt like I belonged
somewhere now where I was returned as a
commander and Starfleet intelligence and
she arrives on the Titan to interrogate
Picard about his efforts to commandeer
the ship to pursue his agenda this gives
Rowan Picard the opportunity to resolve
detention created by their unpleasant
parting and preemptive strike and puts a
bow on Rose canonical Star Trek tenure
with her death in this episode it now
appears that after nearly a three decade
Hiatus we really have seen the last of
Roe laryn the Bounty sees Riker Rafi and
wolf sneak through the vault at daystrom
station they're hoping to learn what the
changelings are after when they burgled
the facility before the start of the
Season as they searched the secret
Archive of Technology they pass by
several displays containing artifacts
from throughout the history of the Star
Trek franchise the label of the first
display we see is too blurry to identify
for certain but it appears to be a
thalerman weapon like the one used by
shinzon in Star Trek Nemesis there's the
Genesis 2 device apparently an upgraded
version of the planet creating machine
from The Wrath of Khan as well as a body
of James T Kirk recovered from Viridian
3 after his burial in Star Trek
generations we also see a borg vinculum
the device that processes the thoughts
of assimilated drones as originally seen
on Star Trek Voyager there's even a
genetically modified treble while on
those specific items from DS9 are seen
aboard the station it's not entirely
left out of the fun the collection
itself is curated by section 31 the
immoral covert Ops organization
introduced in season six of DS9 and what
does section 31 do apart from kidnapping
Starfleet officers we search out and
identify potential dangers to the
Federation
towards the end of Picard's sixth
episode The Bounty the audience learns
that the advanced artificial
intelligence which gas evolves of
daystrom station is in fact a new
synthetic Android the body houses the
restored memories of data his siblings
law B4 Alton sunk and data's daughter
Lal however the clues us to the ai's
identity are laid almost from the moment
Riker Rafi and Wharf arrive at the
station when wolves swaps out the
computer security key with a hacked copy
he acquired a matalis prime the computer
says thank you in a number of different
voices the first of these voices is that
of data himself
thank you thank you the rest of the
clues are sussed out by Riker throughout
the adventure a holographic Crow appears
in a corridor which is an echo of one of
data's dreams from the TNG episode
Birthright later the team is confronted
by Professor Moriarty Moriarty is of
course a fictional character who became
a sentient life form when the Enterprise
computer attempted to create a worthy
adversary for data there are also a few
audio cues the sound of a violin data
primary musical instrument begins
echoing throughout the station and when
Riker recognizes that his playing
excerpts from Pop Goes the Weasel he
flashes back to his first meeting with
data an encounter of farpoint
while on the run from the changeling
infiltrated star Fleet and looking for a
way to rescue the away team from
daystrom station the USS Titan pays a
visit to the fleet Museum the final
resting place of many legendary vessels
several ships are visible including the
Defiance the Enterprise a voyager and
the HMS Bounty there are also a few
other ships visible around the perimeter
of the old space dock eagle-eyed viewers
will make out two examples of the fun
favorite Akira class from Star Trek
first Contact a nebula-class ship
originating from TNG an old style
Romulan bird of prey from the original
series and a Klingon battle cruiser as
seen in Star Trek the motion picture
there is even a constellation class ship
could it be the Stargazer Picard's first
command however one noteworthy ship is
visible only in a few shots and never
gets a close-up the Enterprise nx-01
from Star Trek Enterprise we get a
decent look at it during the Montage of
plays in the Alton soons personal log
and from there we can see that the nx01
has received a refit since its last
appearance on Enterprise it has gotten a
familiar Drive section similar to the
one found on the Constitution class
ships
the safe episode The Bounty brings LeVar
Burton back to a pricer role of Geordie
laforge who is now a star fleet's
Commodore and the curator of the fleet
Museum Geordie also brings along his
daughter Alondra portrayed by Burton's
real-life daughter Mika Burton this
isn't the only backstage bonus that this
episode has to offer when the daystrom
Institute AI which we later learn his
data scans will Riker's face we see his
service record appear on our screen this
confirms some information from official
reference materials like his mother's
name Betty and also gives us Riker's
birthday August 19th the same as actor
Jonathan Frakes there are also the names
of the two staffy vessels to spudge to
pursue the Titan their tributes to
behind the scenes figures from the
show's art Department one is a USS
Sternberg almost certainly named for
artist Rick sternbach designer of
countless Starships Journey TNG DS9 and
Voyager era the other is a USS Core
widely named for Lee Kong she was an art
director and graphic designer who helped
Define the interior aesthetic of the
first TOS films
at the start of the seventh episode
Dominion the Titan is hiding in a scrap
yard in the chintaka system located at
the edge of cardassian space chintaka is
a site of two pivotal battles in the
Dominion war in the Deep Space Nine
episode tears of the prophets Cisco and
the crew of the USS Defiance to let the
Allied Federation Klingon and Romulan
flees in a successful invasion of
chintaka they won the Allies their first
offensive victory of the war the
Dominion wouldn't be on their back foot
for long however the following year in
the changing face of evil they would
retake the system with the aid of their
new members the Breen the Second Battle
of chintaka was a devastating defeat for
the Allies using their deadly energy
dampening weapons the brain tore through
the Federation and Romulan forces this
included the defiant whose wreckage can
be seen floating in the window of the
Titans conference Lounge also visible in
the scrapyard are the remains of a
massive gemidar warship
in the 8th episode surrender Commodore
Geordie the forge reactivates the new
data and he activates the partition
between his different personalities he
hopes that data's personality will win
out over his malevolent brother lore
with whom he currently shares a brain
data is a gentle soul and has no
interest in destroying law whereas law
is only too eager to take his brother
apart piece by piece data realizes that
he can use this to his advantage and
willfully offers up his memories for law
to steal these trinkets are my memories
the only sensible measure of the worth
of a life as low gobbles up aspects of
data's life he unknowingly becomes data
this allows the two personalities to
fuse into a single being this new
personality has data's wisdom and
kindness as well as Law's capacity for
emotion and Whimsy we see this struggle
take place inside the new Android's head
as data manifests as memories in the
form of recognizable props from TNG we
see the handsome pipe from his Sherlock
Holmes costume which he first wore in
the episode Elementary dear data he also
then summons a small holographic statue
of the late Lieutenant Tasha ya data had
a brief intimate relationship with Yar
in the episode The Naked Now the
memorial hologram was first seen in the
measure of a man and later in the most
toys finally dater offers up his cat
spots as a representation of his
capacity to love longtime fans May
chuckle to hear spot referred to as a he
as a cat's sex inexplicably change from
male to female during TNG season 7. spot
is now a boycott again at least in
data's memory
season three's pronouncements episode
Vox shows us a long advertised Frontier
day ceremony in which the entire Active
Star Fleet assembles for a single
demonstration over Earth this
demonstration is displayed on a map
behind the curse a few of the ships were
featured in previous Armada scenes and
Picard's seasons one and two these
include the USS Zhang which Captain
Reicher commands in the standoff of the
romulans in the last episode of season 1
most of the fleet that investigates the
anomaly in the season 2 premiere at the
Stargazer is present here including the
Gilgamesh Sutherland IBN Al Haytham and
the new Excelsior some of the ships are
also named for prominent figures in the
history of Star Trek special effects and
production design the USS okuda which
also appears in the Stargazer is
certainly named for production designers
and authors of multiple Star Trek
reference books Michael and Denise okuda
the USS Drexler pays Homer to the
longtime Star Trek ship designer Doug
Drexler or the USS tromble likely pays
tribute to the late Douglas Trumbull a
Pioneer in special effects who passed
away in 2022 we've also got ships known
for important figures in Star Trek
history like the USS Cochrane the USS
John Kelly named after the pioneering
astronaut from the Voyager episode one
small step and the USS Hikaru Sulu who
needs no introduction
Vox features a surprise appearance by
Elizabeth Dennehy as Shelby a beloved
guest star from TNG two-parter The Best
of Both Worlds in those episodes Shelby
joins a crew of the Enterprise D to
confront the Borg threat even becoming
the ship's new first officer after
Captain Picard is captured by the Borg
though Shelby's role in the two-parter
is memorable she never appears on the
series again her only other canonical
appearance as a cameo in the Animated
Series Star Trek lower decks by which
time she has been promoted to Captain
while she remained and used on
television for decades Shelby became a
main character in Star Trek New Frontier
a long-running series of novels by Peter
David and John aldover in the novel she
receives a first name Elizabeth and is
eventually promoted to the rank of
Amaral Vox makes a point of establishing
Shelby's name in rank as Canon even
placing her in command of the USS
Enterprise F during the frontier day
ceremony
right from the mouth of Admiral
Elizabeth Shelby
in the future of Star Trek Federation
Starships aren't in the habit of
measuring time by the same calendar that
the viewers use at home they still use
the same minutes hours and years but
when someone asks what day it is a star
Fleet officer is bound to respond with
something like star date 47988 over the
years fans have engineered ways to
roughly translate this into Earth dates
but this isn't an exact science every
once in a while however circumstances
provide us with the tools we need to pin
the events of a given episode to an
exact date on our calendar we've known
all along that season 3 of Picard is set
in the year 2401 as confirmed by
showrunner Terry matalis in interviews
it's also implied by the nature of the
frontier Day festivities celebrating the
250th anniversary of Staff lease this
day marks the maiden voyage of the
Enterprise nx01 which began in 2151 in
Vox Admiral Shelby gets even more
specific and no study nx-01's Mission
began 250 years ago today luckily for us
that launched pre-data transition to the
star date calendar so thanks to Captain
Archer's log entry from Broken Bow the
first episode of Star Trek Enterprise we
know that this episode of Picard takes
place on April 16th
several Star Trek alumni make their
return in this episode exclusively in
voiceover most prominently Alice Krieg
who originated the Borg Queen in Star
Trek first Contact and reprized it in
the series finale of Star Trek Voyager
is back she provides the voice of the
board queen during a confrontation with
Jack Crusher Craig succeeds actor Annie
wushing who portrayed the queen in
season 2 of Picard washing died of
cancer in January of 2023 at the age of
45 and this season's Premiere was
dedicated to her memory the later major
Barrett can also be heard in this
episode reprising the role of the
Enterprise D computer of the eclipse of
archival audio barrapolate the default
voice of the Starfleet computer across a
plethora of Star Trek series films video
games and fun works from 1966 until her
death in 2008. she also originated the
roles of Nurse Christine Chapel and
number one on the original series both
of whom are now regular characters on
Star Trek's strange new worlds she might
be best remembered as lordsana Troy
Diana's mother on Star Trek the Next
Generation she was also the wife of
series Creator Gene Roddenberry finally
the voice of captain membersas of the
ill-fated USS Excelsior is provided by
prolific voice actor Nolan North who has
played multiple characters on Star Trek
lower decks he's best known as the voice
of Nathan Drake in the Uncharted video
game series
since the entire modern Starfleet has
been hijacked by the Borg Picard and his
old crew are forced to flee to the fleet
Museum and bring an old Starship out of
moth balls to confront them as luck
would have it Jordy has been secretly
reconstructing the USS Enterprise D on
which he and his surrogate family served
drawing Star Trek the Next Generation
obviously the real reason why Picard's
crew rise in the battle aboard the
Enterprise D and not the more advanced
Enterprise E is because by and large the
viewing audience doesn't have as much
Nostalgia for the dimly lit battleheart
and e as they do for the Cozy and
familiar D the characters do however
offer a funny in-universe explanation
while on route to the university and
space dark Jordi mentions that it's a
shame that they're unable to use the
Enterprise E after which everyone's side
eyes Warf Wharf responds defensively
that was not my fault the light implies
that he is somehow responsible for the
loss of Picard's second Enterprise this
actually lines up with some backstory
provided in a Star Trek Picard Tire
novel The Last best Hope by una
McCormack there we learn that after
Picard is promoted to Amaral he chooses
wolf to succeed him as captain of the
Enterprise E The Exchange in Vox implies
that this is Canon and that wolves
tenure as captain of the Enterprise had
an unexpected conclusion in the
Enterprise's Star Trek Picard lug on
Instagram the ship's final mission is
listed as classified
the series finale the last generation
opens with the crew of the refurbished
Enterprise D listening to an audio
distress call sent by the president of
the United Federation of planets Anton
Chekhov voiced by original Star Trek
cast member Walter Koenig koenig's
casting along with a reference to his
father implies that President Chekhov is
the son of Commander Pavel Chekhov
former Navigator and weapons officer of
the Enterprise under James T Kirk
Chekhov says that his father was fond of
saying there were always possibilities a
phrase favored by Pavel Chekhov shipmate
spark in Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan
Kirk reminds Lieutenant savic of this
fact as your teacher Mr spark has found
a saying I'd like to think that there
always are
possibilities president Chekhov shares
his first name Anton with late actor
Anton Yelchin who portrayed Pavel
cheggov in the rebooted Star Trek film
Trilogy yaochin was tragically killed in
an accident in 2016 making this a
touching tribute to an absent friend the
text of President chekhov's message also
closely resembles one sent by a previous
Federation president in Star Trek for
the Voyage Home when the earth is under
attack by a strange Alien Probe both
messages include the phrases do not
approach Earth and save yourselves
farewell in both the Voyage Home and the
last generation Our Heroes are fugitives
from Starfleet who must return to Earth
in a stolen vessel to prevent a global
disaster while playing the audio message
the text on the Enterprise D's view
screen mentions general order 12 a star
fleet's directive mentioned in Star Trek
2 the Wrath of Khan that requires that
vessels go to Red alerts when any vessel
approaches without first establishing
Communications also noted a Starfleet
order 104 which requires that commanding
officers exhibiting strange Behavior be
really received of Duty and regulation
19 Section C which allows another
officer to take command in an emergency
to retake the bridge of the USS Titan
from the assimilated Junior officers
seven Rafi and a few other grown-ups
rigged phasers with Transporter
technology in order to instantly beam
anyone they shoot into the secure
transporter room the plan works allowing
them to capture their burgerified
Shipmates without timing them job riding
transporter Fields through phasers you
may have just invented the portable beam
me up this particular use of Transporter
technology is something new for Star
Trek but it's not the first time you've
seen portable transporter technology or
the use of a transporter as a weapon on
Star Trek Voyager the vidians use
weapons similar to rafi's new rifles
which fire a phaser-like beam at their
targets that transports individual
organs out of their victims voyages cook
neelix Falls victim to one of these
weapons in the episode phage when a
vidian makes off with both his lungs of
course this happens years before seven
joins the Voyager crew so maybe she
wasn't aware of it similarly in Star
Trek insurrection the sonas employ
drones of fire small transport attacks
beaming whatever they hit up into
holding cells aboard their ship rafi's
rifles seem to be an evolution of this
technology as they do not appear to
require any kind of projectile to lock
onto a Target seventh reference for
portable transporter might actually be a
call forward to a technology that we
know to be commonplace in the distant
future of Starfleet in later seasons of
Star Trek Discovery set over 600 years
after Picard tiny Transporters become
integrated into Starfleet badges
allowing officers to instantly beam
between any two points the last
generation contains a handful of smaller
nods to other Star Trek films and
episodes including some direct visual
references the shot towards the end of
the episode of the Enterprise D and the
Titan a flying side by side framed
against Earth's Sunrise evokes a similar
shot towards the end of Star Trek 6 the
Undiscovered Country in which the
Enterprise a and the Excelsior fly one
final time together before passing ways
the re-christening of the USS Titan as a
new Enterprise parallels and revealed in
Star Trek 4. when the USS Yorktown is
renamed the Enterprise a in tribute to
Kirk and his crew both of these reveals
take place in space dark as the captain
of the old Enterprise approaches via
shuttle in the final scene of the series
Wolff mentions that he will be teaching
a seminar about mugatu meditation it's
possible that Wharf is referencing a
mugato sometimes pronounced mugato which
is a giant horned ape creature seen in
the original series episode a private
little war however it's also possible
that this is a subtle nod to Strange New
World's character Lan nuni and Singh and
her seventh lesson of security leave no
stone Unturned I usually require Cadets
to look under mcgart and breathing
stones for that one well NASA proposal
toes the data breaks into a saucy
Limerick that he once tried to recite in
the season 1 TNG episode The Naked now
just like last time he has interrupted
before he can finish finally we close on
the crew playing poker like in the TNG
finale all good things and the final
shot of the series under the credits has
patterned closely after the final shot
of the Next Generation right down to the
rotation of the camera over the poker
table as Picard deals
foreign